some republicans are beginning to wake
up and figure out what time it is josh
hawley is one of them josh hawley
a u.s senator from missouri is now
threatening to
remove disney's special copyright
protections and to remove major league
baseball's special anti-trust
protections
and he is doing that explicitly because
those two companies are going very woke
so hawley proposed the copyright clause
restoration act which would limit new
copyright protections to 56 years and
retroactively change protections for
companies like disney that quote have
been granted unnecessarily long
copyright monopolies
uh you saw this copyright term extended
in 1998 this was sunny when sonny bono
was a congressman it was the sonny bono
copyright term extension act of 1998 it
was commonly known as the mickey mouse
protection act and disney got a
sweetheart deal on their copyrights
major league baseball has gone super
duper woke in recent years so and major
league baseball most recently uh removed
the all-star game from georgia because
they wanted to protest georgia's
integrity election integrity laws so
josh hawley says that mlb should lose
its long-standing anti-trust exemption
which no other industry enjoys in the
same way there are going to be some
people who who
whine and complain and say this is the
use of the government to target private
corporations this is terrible this is
awful this is
this is
politics folks this is self-government
there's nothing anti-conservative
or unprincipled or un-american about it
this is we the people saying no we're
not going to let giant
usually multinational corporations wield
their massive political power to
completely upend the american way of
life
when you're talking about something like
copyright when you're talking about the
the mickey mouse copyright protection
act or something and josh hawley trying
to get rid of some of disney's special
protections
there's an argument for it and there's
an argument against it i think
reasonable people can disagree over
copyright law and how long copyrights
should exist and what copyrights should
be in movies compared to books compared
to i think reasonable people can
disagree about that i think reasonable
people can disagree about what sort of
special protections big sports leagues
should get
okay there's
this is not just a purely ideological
manner matter where you just write down
three bullet points on the back of a
napkin and this is true conservatism and
this is true progressivism it's politics
folks politics is a big sphere where we
can discuss how we want to live and
where we the people can push back
against the extreme radical predations
of
of
business leaders who are frankly acting
like oligarchs but here's what i'll tell
you
here's what i will tell you when the
people
even when they just saber rattle a
little bit when we the people say we are
willing
to go after woke corporations
it works breaking news at a variety the
trade paper in hollywood
netflix updates its corporate culture
memo
adding anti-censorship section and
vowing to spend our members money wisely
so they came out they that netflix has
said look we're we're not gonna
we're not gonna go woke okay we're not
going to and especially they said we are
not going to cave to our woke employees
which is what happened at disney over
the the parental rights and education
law
they said artistic expression
uh
we have a new section called artistic
expression they will not quote censor
specific artists or voices even if
employees consider that content harmful
they say if you'd find it hard to
support our content breadth
netflix may not be the best place for
you
so they're telling their woke employees
go pound sand we are not going to deal
with this this is in part because there
was a giant woke netflix uproar over a
dave chappelle special last year
but i think what this is really about
is disney i think that if the florida
legislature and governor ron desantis
had not gone after disney and not taken
away disney's special tax exemptions and
not not specifically gone after disney
after disney specifically went after the
voters of florida i don't think you
would see this from netflix right now
i think if you weren't seeing political
actions like josh hawley saying you know
disney
you done messed up disney you just
you just pushed it a little too far
disney and now we're going to make an
example of you because we are not going
to stand idly by while you groom our
freaking kids in your weird lgbt lmnop
transgender nonsense
we're not gonna we're gonna use
everything that we the people still have
we don't have the media we don't have
the educational institutions we don't
have big tech we don't have we don't we
don't have anything
we don't have the government bureaucracy
we have very very little but we do still
have a little bit of a vote in our
legislatures and we're going to use that
power and we're going to say no
and we're going to make life real
unpleasant for you
and if you're netflix over here frankly
the ceo of netflix is probably happy to
see that happen to disney because this
gives the ceo of netflix some cover say
yo guys we're just not going to do it
okay we can't we can't afford to do it
we're getting way too much pushback the
reason that the the libs cave all the
time the reason that the world
corporations cave rather to the libs is
because they say look we just can't take
the pressure
we can't take the threats we can't take
the boycotts we can't take the walkouts
well how about we we conservatives bring
a little bit of pressure too in a
completely moral and principled and
political way i think that's a great
idea this is great news from netflix
good job florida republicans good job
josh hawley
keep it up
when we see
the culture when we see private
enterprise private business
doing this woke virtue signaling
it's more than just silly
it's more sometimes it's just disgusting
and disordered and and needs to be
discouraged as best we can calvin klein
did this today
calvin klein used to put out ads that
were you know kind of saucy kind of
scintillating
i don't think they were exactly obscene
but you know calvin klein you know it's
they
make underwear right they so obviously
they want to
put forward an image of men and women
that is attractive
until recently until they've gone woke
and now they're selling their products
by posting a picture it's it's become
the meme it's the meme of that emoji
it's a pregnant man
ostensibly it's a it's an image of what
looks like a woman
lying with what sort of looks like a man
it's someone with a beard and a buzz cut
but a big pregnant belly and so you
realize oh no this is a this is a woman
who has cut her breasts off and is now
exposing her
mutilated breasts
and taken a bunch of cross-sex hormones
and is pregnant with a baby and so we're
going to show you this topless confused
woman in our ads to sell
underwear the the
caption is today in support of women and
mothers around the world we highlight
the reality of new families
the uh kaye vensel is a south african
painter and mother to wild erica fee and
roberto beet are expecting parents from
brazil roberto is due to give birth to
his and erica's son noah any day now
the nenenda carter
carter is a prominent fashion consultant
her family is bobby and weston
this is wrong
it's wrong can we say it's wrong i know
we're not it's not politically correct
to say that we're not we're supposed to
keep our opinions to ourselves and we'll
be called bigots and phobes and all it's
it's wrong right it's worse it's
disgusting
it is disgusting
that our culture is celebrating women
mutilating their own bodies
and then
redefining all of the most basic human
institutions
and
putting children in a very bad position
and depriving them of their natural
mothers and fathers in many cases all to
satisfy our sexual delusions and desires
and fetishes it's wrong and disgusting
and the culture should discourage it and
stop it and say no
are we allowed to say that am i allowed
to i know
that's
contradicting every woke orthodoxy that
we're now told and yet we all know it's
true we all know it if you showed that
that picture that advertisement
to
a hundred americans at random 99 and a
half of them would say stop this what on
earth are you doing and what does the ad
say it says today
in support of women and mothers around
the world we highlight the reality of
new families
i i don't accept this new definition of
family
do you do you
one there's no limiting principle on it
so there's no definition at all
if we can redefine the family
in this way if we can redefine the
family away from what it actually is
which is mommy and daddy love each other
very much and do that thing that married
people do and that creates a baby if we
can redefine it away from that to say
well it's mommy and
mommy and mommy and mommy daddy and
daddy daddy and daddy and daddy's friend
and a goat if we get what's the limiting
principle there isn't one
and it totally throws open the quest
what is a family what is a family for
what does a family do what distinguishes
a family from a town or a city or a
nation
well the complementarity of the sexes
and the the possibility of creating life
that's that's what distinguishes it as
an as a natural fact okay do we have the
right in this country to stand up for
that
the supreme court tells us no
the
bureaucracy tells us no the radical
activists tell us no but i think we do i
think we still have some political
rights and whoopi goldberg and corinne
jean-pierre and the the people who run
our country and who speak for the people
who run our country they're going to
laugh at us and tell us that they don't
give a damn what we think but i think we
still have some political rights and i
think we have not only the right but a
responsibility
to assert those rights did you like that
clip i'm glad you did make sure you ring
that smash and like that subscribe and
click that doodad and hit the gizmo that
way you will get all of the
notifications for the michael knowles
show you should also go to apple podcast
spotify stitcher google play wherever
you get your audio podcasts make sure
you head on over there and subscribe to
the michael knowles show we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you